what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm Lauren and with me is
law everybody hello everyone he will be
our Channel a lot more so used to his
beautiful face today we're going to talk
about what everybody's talking about so
let's join the conversation is Marvel
dead it's Marvel dying
I think no
um but but but but
have things been have we had some poor
quality content yes but you know
initially what do you think because I've
seen I've seen like a bunch
of videos on this already like like
right when secret Invasion finale came
out people were like on it like making
videos like Marvel's dead is Marvel's
dead can they come back what are your
thoughts just like right away law well
you know I yeah it's such a dramatic
thing to say it's so dramatic right you
know what I mean like and it's been
happening since end game and I I know
people that were big Marvel fans that
that even hated endgame and I'm like how
do you hate any game it's like it's like
everything that we led up to and I and
we'll get into this but that's what's
lacking in the MCU right now is that I
don't feel like we're headed in a
direction we're headed in multiple
directions and uh is Marvel dying I
certainly hope not because I still enjoy
a lot of it but did I enjoy everything
that they're coming out with absolutely
not uh and so I I think it's like a
weird phase of uh experimentation and
and trying to appease the audience and
also possibly like bad work environment
so yeah
it's gonna be an interesting time to see
how it uh figures itself out but I'd
like to optimistically say that it's not
dying but it does need triaging it does
need some first shade sure sure it makes
sense that's fair and uh what we're
going to do today is we're actually
gonna we'll we'll pull up you know some
of the older phase one the phase three
movies obviously we don't have any
Disney Plus shows to compare to because
there were none before then
you know we'll talk about the quality of
them and we'll also talk about the
future as well because that's I think
considering the future is like the
biggest factor of is Marvel dying like
yeah first of all
I think Marvel I I hope
I hope Marvel is smart enough
to hear the audience yeah and and
realize that like okay you know they're
losing tons like literally millions of
Disney plus subscribers right uh you
know ticket sales for a lot of just
Disney projects in general are bad right
right so
I I hope they kind of get something in
their brain that goes like Hey we're
kind of losing touch with the audience a
little bit like let's listen and hear
what they want to say so like did you
did you like secret invasion
um you know I liked it to a point and I
was just kind of let down but you hear
the word secret Invasion and as a comic
book fan I I immediately draw into you
know like different storylines yeah it's
and it's nothing in comparison we all
like it yeah even in the MCU secret
Invasion doesn't really leave a dent
except for a spoiler alert if you
haven't seen it the most powerful
character now being Gaia you know what I
mean like yeah when that happened I was
like oh come on dude because Captain
Marvel is already op and now we have
like a Peter Petrelli version of all
those Powers I I love Emilia Clarke I
did not I don't think this was the
vessel to make her like the most
powerful being in the MCU and I was
really let down by the overall story of
secret Invasion but that's my problem
with Disney Plus shows uh especially the
Marvel ones right you see it in the Star
Wars realm too but since we're sticking
to Marvel
they have strong Concepts and strong
starts but somewhere halfway through the
season there's a quality drop off that
seems to be sorry to cut you off just
real quick that does seem to be a
yeah it just that's common I feel it's
like a pattern now yeah like at first it
wasn't and then you're like I hope for
the best it's a pattern now it is I just
got done telling you about Miss Marvel I
really loved the show in the beginning
and today I love Mont belongings Miss
Marvel she's perfect because but like
third episode fourth episode I'm like
what is this writing like what you know
what are some of these effects it's it
is but sorry go ahead continue yes the
quality up to a certain point exactly
that you know like Miss Marvel's a great
example it's a it's a show that I really
loved you know they showed you know I'm
South Asian so seeing like the great
partition happening like all that stuff
was really rich and full of like uh
detail that I I like wanted to eat up
but you have six episodes to tell these
stories and it's never enough you know
what I mean I feel like the the writing
in that second half of the season is
like how do we tie all this [__]
together yeah
you gotta get it finished let's go you
know Secret Invasion fell into maybe
probably the worst version of that
because they were like here's this world
we set up and let's not address most of
this stuff let's talk about Nick Fury's
love life let's talk about Graphics like
power grab and then by the end I'm like
why did we have this show to kill off
two really cool characters that's what I
said the other day like to kill off two
characters and give us one super op one
was that the whole point
um and I I don't know that that's like
the quality thing you I saw a glimpse of
it in one Division and Loki but
obviously those are some of the stronger
shows that we've had yeah amazing shows
but you got to admit during the finales
of those shows because of the way the
audience thinks and because of the
discussions that we get to have online
it they can feel underwhelming you know
you can't see it I get what you're
saying you're blaming me because I
pushed Mephisto so much for One Division
I see what you're doing I'm not doing it
all right the internet's doing it I'm
just reiterating I've already dealt with
this this is PTSD now yeah but you're
right dude some somewhere along the way
the writing gets messy and then like
sorry I had to bring up secret evasion
again but like when the director doesn't
look at the source material that worries
me as like a as a big old nerd because
it's just like at the very least you
want the spirit to carry over like and
it doesn't always no and this like again
like you said like for the people who
have read the comic there's nothing like
it nothing at all this is so here's a
problem for me that I think is a problem
with Marvel right now
I feel like
weird like too many characters are just
like made too powerful really quick yeah
like that was Captain Marvel and this is
It's Gaia now and I'm like what happened
to like the struggle of becoming
the hero yeah right like it's it's just
kind of like and like yeah some people
could say like well you know guy lost
her mom she lost her dad but it's like
okay but before that
you know she can take the skin of a
human live a human life you know what I
mean like it's just like I'm not seeing
a lot of like physical struggle or
struggle for you know there is some
struggle there with being displaced in
people you know in in an immigrant story
which I get at the same time I'm like
okay yeah you just you just got you just
became a super scroll like you jumped in
a machine and like there it is all of a
sudden you can beat gravic like I'm like
that's so easy and it's like the same
thing with Captain Marvel it's like oh
the power was inside you all along and
it's just like no you need to grow and
build the power and struggle and that's
how that's what makes the the victory
better that's what makes it sweet right
yeah sorry I go for it oh you just you
think of like like Captain America look
at his struggle the scrawny little guy
and then he became and then he still
struggled after he became like Captain
America he lost Bucky right he he lost
the love of his life he got prison in
the ice like he still had to deal with
stuff even when he got powers right so
there was still more fighting same thing
with Thor right he lots of hammer yeah
became unworthy he he basically lost to
the destroyer and then through all of
that he came to the realization because
he grew as a person as a character to
become who he well who he was now he's a
goofball but
who he was and um and then he became
like Thor and then it was like I'm
worthy again and I'm like yes we don't
have that anymore if they were writing
Thor the way it did now he won he
wouldn't just be unworthy to have his
hammer in the first place he or if he
wasn't worthy be a hammer he just would
have been like you know what I can be
better and I am better bam worthy I went
like that's how I feel like it would be
written now sure yeah I'm really tired
of the like it's all it's inside which
don't get me wrong like yeah that's it's
good like
you have the power to be better is what
I would say every real person does but
you can't just flip a switch and then
it's it's done it takes work yeah it
takes work and that's what I that's what
I think has been missing lately is like
the hero's not doing work they're just
op first of all I'm tired of really op
Heroes but you know they're not doing
any work to become op like I want that
struggle yeah we I think as fans we
enjoy seeing Heroes lose and then win
yeah for sure it's funny that we're
having this conversation because you
know take us back 10 years ago and
people would have been complaining that
Thor is not powerful enough that cap is
was nerfed from the comics you're not
wrong you know what I mean but now now
we're in a place where it's like because
they set up this world in that way when
I see someone manipulating energy in a
way that like I haven't even seen some
of the heaviest hitters in the MCU do
you know then I then I I have that
complaint too or it's just like where is
this coming from why do we need them to
be this op and then and then it makes
you worried about like okay are we still
building up to Kang like how does Kang
fight Gaia at this point or two Captain
Marvel you know what I mean he couldn't
beat ants yeah he couldn't beat ants
yeah it's pissed me off like that it was
so underwhelming it was so underwhelming
I'm like dude and he was soaked and
Jonathan Majors is great at playing like
yes his performances gang is awesome
he's menacing and you're like quiet when
you watch him you're like you want to
listen to him you want to listen to him
it's so great and you're he's like
conquered all of these worlds and it
shows him just how ruthless he is and
I'm just like and then
and and that's like another problem with
with Marvel right now is that you get
these villains that have a lot of what I
would think you'd call it gravitas right
you call it character like gravic was
spitting some sick monologues but the
rest of the writing around the show
wasn't as good and so so when he
eventually loses I'm like what the [__]
was the point of setting it up you know
what I mean like give us the super
scroll if you're gonna give us a super
scroll let him exist Beyond this
um but you see it with like you know
Doctor Strange no way home I loved well
I'll start with that Shang Chi no way
home even eternals I really enjoy then
you go into like Multiverse of Madness
the quality drops off love Sam Raimi
love like the the vibe of the movie did
not like the movie overall in in like a
big way I think I gave it like a c or C
minus in my head you know Thor love and
thunder really enjoyed it but did it
have impact on the timeline not really
Gore was underwhelming as as a character
especially when you're coming from
Ragnarok with like hella is so cool
and then like I think the anomaly was
like what guardians of galaxy vol 3 and
wakanda forever really great highlights
right but then you look at quantumania
and I feel like it just wasn't handled
with the same care or respect which is
really really frustrating then you get
secret Invasion versus like
you know like I like Hawkeye I did not
really like Falcon and Winter Soldier I
liked wander Vision I like Loki I liked
Moon Knight uh I liked a lot of She-Hulk
but not all of She-Hulk so it's like the
fact that I have I don't know maybe it's
just because we have so much content now
that it's hard to make everything good
but that's that in itself is an issue I
think it is and so this is we'll go into
like the Future Part now because we
could talk about a lot for a long time
about what is currently happened but I'm
with you like not gonna win a soldier
was all right I honestly kind of don't
remember
yeah
that's sad right I could tell you
everything that happened in one division
everything that happened in Loki I loved
Moon night right but like the fact is
what you just said is they're putting
out so much not all of it's gonna be
good especially when they do a show like
She-Hulk that is uh appealing to like a
very specific audience right Niche yeah
yeah you're blocking out like if this is
a pie chart right of
the the Marvel fan base and you're
taking just a chunk of that you know
you're blocking out a lot of people so
when it's not successful that's why now
it's cool that you're going into niches
and trying to appeal to like specific
people that's really really cool but
moving forward they have said they're
gonna do less content
yeah yeah I think
I'll go back to what I said before I
want to say I think but I'll really say
I hope
you don't know right yeah that less
content means better quality content and
so in my mind if you're putting out four
Disney Plus shows a year and you cut
back to two those Disney Plus shows can
be Nine episodes long and they can all
be an hour long because now we have more
budget now we have more time now we have
more care
you know that's my thought so when
people ask me like are Marvel is Marvel
dying like no they've already have they
put some bad stuff out sure and there
are people out there really like secret
Invasion and I honestly sure I like the
fight but I hate
there was some good action else
literally everything else about the
finale bro there was some good action
but like I couldn't understand scroll
motivation like the there were enough
secret Scrolls like there's so many
things I can nitpick but my biggest
problem with that show is that you
mentioned it just a second ago but like
you get a big budget and then when I
can't see that budget in the quality of
the show that drives me crazy so if
you're giving 200 million dollars for a
show yeah I want to see 200 million
dollars worth of like great writing and
effects and and production value granted
they they had a crazy cast that they had
to pay but can we not adjust for that
you know what I mean so if we're going
to a model of like a couple a couple
shows a year then I would hope that it's
like okay we give them 200 000 we give
them maybe even 12 episodes for a season
right you know yeah because yeah go live
I think
degrees six episodes is is not enough to
do anything well
no it's not especially when they're like
38 minutes long yeah well secret
invasions last episode was like so short
and I was like what's the point yeah for
sure and thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now if you go to hellofresh.com
cosmic50 you can use code Cosmic 54 50
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com Cosmic 50 and use code
Cosmic 50 for 50 off plus free shipping
well so like the biggest thing to me is
I I do think the quality has suffered
and I don't know why
or having such short episodes but I
don't know what goes on behind the
scenes to me either like decided that
that's what it is but I think like like
Daredevil is what 18 episodes long so
yeah so yeah that's supposed to be the
the biggest change right yeah right so I
that makes me really optimistic and I I
think I know Kevin feige and I think
he's gonna really handle that with care
because yeah it's a daredevil he's very
loved from the Netflix series it's still
him yeah yeah Charlie Cox you know play
Matt Murdock Daredevil and I I think
it's going to be handled very well and I
look at like if we take a look at the
future slates right like if we if we
take a look at like what's coming up for
phase five yeah it looks fantastic so we
talk about like the Loki trailer that we
just got I'm like wow yeah that looks
amazing yeah and here's a big thing that
I think these other movies are about
these other movies and shows are about
to do they're gonna tie in more with the
overall story of the MCU because you're
right like with the exception of like
quantumania we haven't really seen much
effect and you know what made me mad was
that
some insiders are saying like
secret Invasion isn't really going to
affect that much like some I heard
someone say you know you're gonna be
surprised how little they talk about
secret evasion in the marbles I'm like
what do you mean that's a direct
follow-up yeah seriously you would think
that's like literally the direct
follow-up yeah right same thing with uh
Captain America Brave New World they're
not gonna really address a lot of the
politics of it and because it's going to
be kind of a political movie because
Thunderbolt Ross is going to be the
president I'm like how are you not going
to do that but if we look at like you
know Loki season two and I know a lot in
all honesty I think the marbles looks
really good yeah I think it looks really
really good I hope it's executed
properly but then we have blade
ironheart Agatha coven of chaos uh uh
Daredevil Thunderbolts Captain America
New World Order I think these are going
to be great and they are going to tie
into the bigger picture of the MCU
I I think if they give them the care
that they need and make sure the writing
is on point and and and show us the
actual budget like you said give the
actual quality I think we're in for a
real treat in all honesty right there
are some like iron heart is probably
what I'm least interested in I like
sorry Echo is what I'm least interested
oh dude I totally forgot about Echo
exactly a lot of people do what's not a
great sign is they're releasing all the
episodes at one time yeah that's also a
good point which is what I thought they
should have done for secret Invasion
because yeah it would have been more
exciting to binge yeah right you almost
wonder if that is a better strategy and
we'll have to see with Echo I've
actually heard good things about Echo oh
that's good yeah I've heard good things
about Echo and you know the character to
me is interesting I just uh
story wise you know she's not typical
you know she wasn't a main character in
Hawkeye or she was one of the main
characters but not like the main
character so I'm sitting here wondering
like it's going to be interesting enough
it's going to be exciting enough but you
know ironheart is even still going to
have connections to a bigger picture
right with armor Wars right with you
know and knock on wood all this stuff
you know whatever that jinx me lafista
is supposed to be in it as well right
deadline reported Sasha bear Cohen's in
it and they reported that yeah I believe
he's playing with Fisto and then you
know there's that whole Supernatural
side like blade you know connecting with
black knight and Moon Knight right and
Doctor Strange and and the midnight Sons
Agatha Covenant chaos doing that you
know Supernatural side as well yes that
and then Daredevil connecting to like
the street level Avengers team with
Spider-Man and with Captain America and
Captain America is supposed to start the
new Avengers team in that film and
introduce Red Hulk
right and then the Thunder the
Thunderbolts is just a really cool
Concept in general and we've already
seen that throughout the MC right with
black women post credits and stuff like
that like that's already been connected
and the Thunderbolts team in general is
a big connected team yeah for sure
people we've seen before it's the
Avengers but but bad earth right you
know what I mean like yeah yeah yeah
exactly so there are some really great
things coming up sure
but like you said I think it's just
about quality yeah like they're gonna
yeah one of the things that that the
biggest change if you look back to when
we started where we're at is that star
power started to become such a thing in
the MCU who got cast as stuff you know I
mean we got a movie with freaking
Angelina Jolie in it which is something
I would have never guessed yeah yeah and
you look at like the the talent behind
who's directing things right like these
are not small names anymore uh and and
in that in that regard you know people
like Anthony Mackey have become Global
Superstars you know people like
um uh you know Elizabeth Olsen are now a
household name even though her career
has been robust and and and really
impressive before the MCU and so now
we're in a balancing act I think where
it's just like okay we have all this
these star Powers we have Amelia Clark
we have Sam Jackson
but that shouldn't take away from the
story right and so like like you said
like we have a bunch of sick titles
coming yeah um but on first glance
truthfully you're not like oh I I love
all these Heroes like I love Loki I love
Guardians sure it's a new but it's a new
Captain America Thunderbolts is a brand
new team made of villains essentially
which is a crazy cool concept yeah yeah
and so there there is there's hope I'll
say that there's a lot there's a lot of
Hope yeah there's a lot of and we and we
didn't even talk about it but you know
upcoming phase six two Avengers films
which sound fantastic so secret secret
Wars obviously yeah Multiverse collapse
and all this stuff and then and then
four oh yeah wow F4 yep yeah but I'm
with you I think there was a time where
Marvel made the actors yes Superstars
and now they're kind of getting the
superstars and that actually takes away
from the budget yeah and and the the
performance sometimes like I love Samuel
L Jackson I cannot say confidently that
he gave it his all during secret
Invasion yeah you know what I mean yeah
you wonder how much he was really in it
yeah and so so I don't
it's it's so hard to predict how things
would go but the the setups are going to
be happening like we're finally
addressing the celestial in the ocean
we're finally you know Daredevils coming
back yes he has an inbuilt audience but
then it's a it's a balancing act of like
you know satisfying old fans but then
also bringing in the Disney the Disney
version of that character and those fans
blade I know is going through a whole
lot of you know the whole industry is
going through some [__] everything's
going through a lot right now and that
and that's actually should be like a
good opportunity to kind of like sit
down and go let's review this stuff
let's do this right yeah they have to
know
we'll close with this they have to know
that
fans have not like a good majority of
the fans haven't enjoyed a lot of what
they've done recently and don't get me
wrong I'm a guy that like I kind of like
enjoy everything but I mean I think
everything's an A plus yeah I can enjoy
something with it being a c plus I don't
think it's like the greatest thing in
the world but I can sit there and and be
like I don't I don't hate myself for
watching that bro I get it I like
eternals you know
that people hated eternals and liked
Dune to me I'm like that's they're the
same style of movie but anyways there's
like we just talked about there's a lot
of Hope and I think because there's a
lot of hope it definitely means Marvel's
not dead and I definitely think if
Marvel has like two maybe three more
flops they're gonna totally change
things up oh yeah because I believe
that's what Kevin feige would do and in
fikey We Trust I think if feige gets a
lot more involved with things like it
used to be he can flip the switch so
quickly and he's a big reason and these
projects are a big reason and the
connectivity is really a big reason why
I think no Marvel's not dead I think the
MCU is about to actually take a pretty
big turn and get a lot more exciting
so just my thoughts what do you think I
I I'm optimistic alongside you I hope I
hope for the same thing I think there's
been enough feedback from fans feedback
and critics for for Marvel Studios to to
look at kind of the big picture and say
let's make some adjustments and we're
seeing that already slowing down the
content you know what I mean yeah
exactly that that is a big sign of of
change to come uh but you're exact I
think you're exactly right if if a
couple stinkers come out then then we're
looking at a real big uh rework and then
it's hard to say how much of phase six
will hold at this point giving you know
the politics of the situation
um the entertainment industry as a whole
and and people like the people involved
I am very hopeful but
um but I'm cautious I'll say that that's
a great thing to say yeah that's a great
way to say it hopeful and cautious but
again I
I I feel like the secret Invasion the
finale for that is the biggest
displacement we've seen from fans
in a what right you know what I mean
like I feel like a lot of fans have
really been and again it is it's what
kind of sent the internet over the edge
and that's when all the Marvel's dead
stuff started popping up
so I think this actually might be a key
moment for Marvel right now since the
writer strikes and everything are going
on for them to take a step back
and be like let's connect with our
audience again a little bit more and and
let's really think about these stories
ha like let's make true Marvel stories
where it's it's a story of growth and
development and character building and
eventually a Triumph right yeah you
can't have a Triumph without overcoming
something
which I I hope we see more but I think
this will I think I think like you said
Marvel has taken a step back already
Disney's taken a step back already and
been like you know what maybe we
shouldn't focus on gaining as many
Disney plus subscribers as possible by
producing a bunch of content let's take
a step back and just make good stuff
again I think that's where we're at
uh
I'm I hope that's why I said that
somebody yeah I think we're hopeful
because we're also fans at the end of
the day right like exactly like we don't
have control over over what gets put out
uh but you know how we react that's the
only thing that we we have control over
but but it's just a quality thing at the
end of the day like I used to love the
Marvel one shots and and I loved how
they felt like little short films and
then yeah and then we're getting a whole
like a whole season of a character like
Moon Knight dude I was so excited Moon
Knight was getting his own show I was so
excited that Hawkeye was getting a show
and then uh you know and we and we got
to see Kate Bishop on screen like like
all those things were really exciting
but it's always that last couple
episodes or the last episode that just
lets you down a little bit and
um and I I just don't know where in the
storytelling process that that ball gets
dropped so I'm hoping whatever comes out
there is no ball dropping you know it's
a steady it's a steady progression to
where we want it to be uh and and and
like I said we we can't control that we
can only watch it and enjoy it or watch
it and and critique it
um but I'm generally curious how other
fans are feeling right now uh you know
you see it online and you see people
reacting uh I mean and the answer for
the big question is is Marvel dying no
one really knows uh that that's gonna be
a collective decision I think from the
fandom right because like I mean all
hating something then yeah it's dead but
there's enough people liking stuff
there's enough people who enjoy Miss
Marvel uh She-Hulk you know that last
that last episode was pretty alienating
for some but I actually really liked
that last episode and then you have like
secret Invasion where it's just like
lead up lead up lead up genre film like
this is awesome oh never mind it's not
it's not really that oh
yeah well and and one thing we didn't
talk about which is a whole nother
podcast oh yeah but the X-Men are coming
I yes I know it's and that's gonna be a
complete tunnel shift in the MCU yeah to
take the shift from The Avengers to the
X-Men like that's gonna be crazy if we
don't get crazy if we're not leading up
to it Avengers versus the X-Men film
eventually what the [__] are we doing oh
sorry
you've already you've already dropped
one did I yes this slips out
but like Honestly though like
that's an American statement what you
just said what are we doing yeah if not
gonna build up to that one day and I
actually think we really are gonna build
up to that with the way secretvasion at
the end really did alienate Scrolls yeah
you know what I mean like they actually
did really be like we're gonna find you
we're gonna kill you anyone for anyone
that porn on this planet it's not
welcome here it's kind of like yeah I
can see how they're not gonna like the
mutants you know yeah so 100 percent
do I think Marvel's dying no do I think
they put out some bad stuff recently
sure
but with everything they have coming up
Fantastic Four the X-Men all these
connected projects and exciting projects
coming up I mean Daredevil 18 episodes
long like I think
I think you know what's great is if
they're 18 18 episodes long they can be
30 so they can be 40 minutes so there's
more room to play yeah exactly so I'm
really excited for that I am excited for
the future but like you said I'm a
little cautious as well but yeah hang in
there Marvel fans because I think I
think we're about to see that shift and
I I think Disney's really listening I
think they really really see what's
going on and they're gonna make a change
as well so I'm hopeful
and still very excited for the future
but let us know what you all think in
the comments down below what are your
thoughts on all of this please let us
know don't forget to follow law I don't
know where I'm gonna put him when I edit
this
I think he's good like bear like over
there so don't forget to follow the law
um you can check out his Instagram
handle we'll put that in the description
and in the pin comment you can follow me
on Instagram as well and of course don't
forget to subscribe to the channel we'll
catch you all next time
bye